[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا فيكم مشاهدينا
في حفله الفنان عبد المجيد عبد الله
الحفله التاريخيه اللي صار عليها اقبال
كبير من قبل المحبين والاف المعجبين
الفنان عبد المجيد عبد الله صباح العربيه
متواجد اليوم كلكم الاجواء الرائعه في
مسرح الفنان محمد عبده
حنيت واهني خافقي ولا انت مش لك
استوصف سما قدرك عجزت توفيق
وشبعت السماء
همم متفق مع مع روتانا طبعا اداره الاستاذ
سالم الهندي انه حرام يعدي الموسم ما نعمل
ما نعمل الحفله ثالثه ان شاء الله نعملها
ان شاء الله بدا الان فنان عبد المجيد عبد
الله في اولى اغانيه في هذه الليله
التاريخيه في مسرح همم الفنان محمد عبده
ليله تاريخيه اجواء رائعه حضور كبير
[موسيقى]
ساعه ساعه ونص كده يعني والحمد لله
عبد المجيد عبد الله يعني امير طرب دائما
انت تفاصيلك ايه ضعفي لا تسال ليه
حنانك ضحكتك هبتك وطيبه اصلك هلا تاريخيه
اطرفيها الفنان عبد المجيد عبد الله
جمهوره ليله طربيه تغنى فيها باغانيها
الجديده والقديمه يا صباح العربيه محمد
خالد الرياض